The joe rogan experience.
And also it's like try getting really high on a really good weed and start
thinking about those fucking drones zooming around Afghanistan and blast and
missiles at kids and it's like you'll really start getting a clear understanding
of how fucked up that is.
You know,
no matter what even let's say even those drone attacks we had to do them,
it's still fucked up.
It still creates more of a sensitivity towards,
um,
people getting their limbs blown off of their bodies,
in the pursuit of some ridiculous war.
And that kind of,
you know,
that's hitting the military industrial complex.
It's hitting the pharmaceutical companies because if you start getting high,
you're going to start experiencing a,
a better level of happiness.
It's going to make you start dealing with your bullshit.
Or maybe it'll make you depressed because you're lazy,
but either way,
it won't allow you to like sink into the kind of sedated hypnosis that it seems
like that works really fucking well for Applebee's.
You know,
it works really well for the corporations,
for people to be in a sedated hypnotic state where they can really make sense of
going down to a shopping mall and and like eating at a fucking,
I dunno,
chicken place with their,
with their kids and then going up and buying some shit.
I'm a shoe store and then spending their day just consuming shit they don't
really need and then going home and sitting back to watch TV with more
advertisements and not thinking that's weird and falling asleep and that kind of
depress lumber that is really hard to do if you're high,
if you're really high,
it's really hard to watch normal TV and not be like,
this is horrible.
Look at these advertisements.
Are you kidding?
They think that that that's going to work on me.
Oh my God,
$48,000 for a fucking car you're going to pay for.
That's like over a year's wage.
For some people you're going to make sense of buying a brand new car payments of
$285 a month.
When you for like four grand,
you can go buy a fucking car,
get it fixed up through the year and have like a shitload extra money and not be
in debt.
That's what pot makes you think.
If you're,
you know,
but if you're like drunk and you're fucking scratching your balls and watching
the game and a fucking the new Lexus,
you'll start thinking like,
well,
my credit score went up this year.
I think I might be able to take out a loan from the bank and get a new Lexus.
Even though you're fucking broke and living in hell and it's going to just
create this weight on your budget that's going to make you miserable.
Dude,
I don't mean to go on a long rant,
but did I ever tell you the time a friend of mine picked me up and his fucking
Mercedes and took me to his apartment.
They would tell you this.
No.
You had a brand new Mercedes and I know this guy knew what his job was picking
me up in his and I knew he can afford a Mercedes.
Picks me up in his brand new Mercedes and he's like,
Hey,
I got to stop by my apartment.
Come inside for a second,
go into his apartment.
It is a size of a fucking closet.
It is the smallest I've ever seen in my life.
Like barely could eat like he had to like kind of like almost like walk sideways
against the wall to get around the bed to get to the bathroom.
It's like a New York style just shit box.
Meanwhile that guy's car payments have gotta be like five 5,600 a month.
I mean this is a nice fucking Mercedes and in his mind he had like his logic
behind it was like yeah it's better to have like a really nice car then like a
comfortable living situation.
I talk about this like a d one last thing.
That guy is a tramp Daemon cause why?
Cause he's a tramp demon because Trump see that Mercedes and they're like let's
go back to your apartment cause they think he's rich and then they get in this
tiny little fucking shitty closet space.
We have some rap about that.
They're making my new place or fixing up town.
I'm staying here for a little while.
Yeah.
So fucking set the look on those Trump's face when they walk in that door and
realize that they barely room to stand.
There's like two feet of carpet between the door and the bed.
There's a lot of people who believe in those really small sustainable houses.
You know,
that people are making these like really,
really little houses and you like move things out for the kitchen and move
things up in the bed is like a little scenario and you know,
and yeah,
like it's,
it's like a whole trend on the internet.
There's a lot of people who are doing that and that's cool.
I don't think there's anything wrong about living simply.
It's just hilarious when people,
uh,
oh yeah,
no,
they throw themselves into a hellish debt,
uh,
for a symbol and,
and,
and well,
it's not just that,
honestly,
it's a,
you,
you enjoy the fuck out of a nice car.
You get an a Mercedes.
You can't believe you're allowed to drive this thing.
Everywhere you go,
people look at you like you must be special looking at,
he's getting into that Mercedes.
I'm like,
oh my God.
For a lot of people that is a tangible benefit of having a car like that they
liked this quarter.
You could say it's shallow all day,
but men driving one of those things is beautiful.
It's an amazing piece of engineering and as a a year head,
you know I'm sort of a minor league area because I don't know exactly how all
that works.
Yeah.
But like Adam Corollas,
like a legit gearhead and he can like build cars.
I just like buy them from people who know how to build them and they appreciate
the fuck out of him.
I think they're interesting.
But the driving one you've drive like a really well engineered piece of,
it's amazing,
man.
I,
if I had shit shitloads of money,
I would buy a nice car and I wouldn't feel weird about it.
Cause anything to like to to dull the fucking existential harder that comes over
me on the one oh one and traffic.
That's beautiful.
I'm just saying when those commercials,
you know they're are,
they're not just appealing to rich people,
they're,
they're manipulating eds into somehow convincing them that logically makes sense
to get in debt to a bank for 50 grand.
It's not just idiots.
It's people that are not happy.
That's what they're offering you happiness.
See,
most people throughout their day,
they have a job that can occasionally be interesting,
but they would never fucking do for free.
And whether they're good at or not,
it takes some sense of pride in their work.
They get through their day,
but they're fucking tired,
man.
And people were unsatisfied.
They feel like they worked so fucking hard.
They put so much and what am I getting?
I'm just existing.
This is what I'm doing.
I'm existing.
So what do they do?
They get fucking shit.
They buy a new bowling ball.
They get a new,
they get a new Lexus and no one for them.
You know,
for some of them you say it's sad,
but for some of those guys that are stuck in that life,
no matter what they do,
that might prevent that might give them like a little bit more happiness
driving,
you know,
plastic,
a nice new Mustang and the way that word classic fucking fruit.
I mean really the idea is get underneath that.
Don't start.
You're starting at the top start way deep.
Start down deep and then worry about the fucking Mercedes and yes for you.
Yes,
for you,
for a guy who thinks,
but for someone who's just locked into the life of a drone and accepts it and
Nice Little Red Mercedes,
look at that.
Look at the look on Bob's face.
He's so happy.
Then he gets into his red Mercedes.
Even in the girls,
hey girls,
I don't buy Mercedes,
but I did.
I get myself in debt.
Always have been.
I did the same shit.
I don't buy Mercedes or our go to that crazy.
But my shit was always like,
I grew up super poor and then now I have credits.
So now I could buy things and Duke,
like the most of my life was like,
hand me down shit.
Or you know,
like shitty toys or you know,
just not like you walk,
you live in a neighborhood with a bunch of kids and get anything they wanted.
Growing up,
I can't,
I don't have to see these kids.
And you're like,
wow,
you got vultron,
how'd you get Voltron?
That's just like $80 you know?
And then now you're an adult,
you're kind of over like,
you feel like,
I deserve this because I didn't have that stuff growing up.
I,
I want what I want.
You know,
like,
like these kids always had growing.
He fucking like objects have to sue them,
give me a big computer monitor and fucking world of Warcraft and some medicinal
marijuana and that's all I need.
And that costs 1399 a month.
Okay.